so if you're a guy who has a small
appendage
first of all you can do something about
it second of all it takes time it takes
consistent effort but it is worth it
putting in the effort and the time
because
especially if you are currently
associating you know your sense of
confidence especially your sense of
confidence in the bedroom around like
the size of your appendage
when you increase it naturally that
confidence is going to skyrocket
because you're a totally different man
right
he also touched on things like premature
ejaculation so
once i get through these couple of
points i'm gonna start giving this guy
some tips on
growing stuff and then on the premature
ejaculation stuff because it's also very
important
but the third thing i want to talk about
is
sex is a learnable skill right being
good in bed is a skill
it is something that requires experience
and know-how
like guys who have you know low notch
counts
or you know haven't had that much sex in
their life
they don't have the prerequisite
experience that someone like me has for
example
who knows all the different buttons to
push on a woman who's had lots of
reference experience who's seen
patterns again and again in terms of
what turns women on what doesn't turn
women on
what compliant body language looks like
in the bedroom what non-compliant body
language looks like in the bedroom so i
know i can do certain things to a woman
if she does this
if she does x if she doesn't why i know
what to do and where to do it
so that is also something that he can
learn which
puts him far above the competition
because he's he's sort of
going in his mind he's like oh just
because i have a tiny dick
no one will ever find me compelling in
the bedroom and it's a complete lie
i can guarantee you out there somewhere
there is an mma fighter with a tiny
appendage
who is absolutely rocking his wife's
world every night in the bedroom because
he can go
like he can throw around and do a whole
bunch of really dominant things in the
bedroom to it
and when you're a guy who knows how to
do that it separates you from the pack
so he's worrying about girls like not
wanting to have one night stand with him
and not being able to kick them in
rotation and he's worried about being
not being spin plates and being taken
advantage of
you know financially in long-term
relationships well
when you can do stuff that no other guy
can
then bam like spinning plates is easy
it's like a rotating door
they just come in and out it's not a
problem
uh so where should we start rich should
i start with uh
the pp stuff yeah let's deal with the
tools guys and
and how guys can grow it like i know
that you've got some some
some serious like tools of the trade
that you have in a course which i'll
link to later but
give them some ideas i mean i've got
some experience um
you know as well with things like um you
know the rocket and the hydro max and
all that sort of stuff like that so
fill them in yeah exactly so like i said
there's a bunch of stuff in my book
about this but
let's give you some free tools you can
use right now so totally totally free
it's not going to cost you anything
uh the the well
there's a couple of tools here let's
start with
jelqing so jilking is how do you spell
that just so they can look it up if they
want
j-e-l-q
j-e-l-q a-e-l-q okay
so gel king is a technique is a manual
technique you can do it you
you have to sort of see videos and
diagrams of it done to understand how to
do it properly
uh kind of hard for me to sort of show
that on camera without rich getting
banned
but it's a
process like a massage you do on your
junk that
forces blood through
your shaft and forces the the shaft to
sort of expand
and doing that consistently for
increased reps increased time and
attention over on that period of time
you will start to get and expand the
shaft so
with this guy there actually another
interesting thing i need to mention here
is that
when you talk to women about
penis size what you'll notice and i've
seen this time and
time again because you know the girls in
my industry talk about this a lot
whenever it refers to a big penis they
always refer they're referring to the
girth
not the length guys when they hear when
when guys talk about having a big wang
they're talking about the length but
when women talk about it they're
actually talking about the girth because
that's what they feel
because they want that sensation of
being filled up right
so the beautiful thing with the joking
exercise is that you can
you can tailor it to work lengthwise
or girth-wise depending upon the amount
of blood that is already in your
shaft so you can have
typically like if you go say say at a
full erection you're at like 100
blood flow in your penis right
if you want to work on lengthening
the shaft then you should start joking
at around about like
30 to 40 percent blood flow
if you want to work on the girth however
you can in
about the range of about 60
to 70 80 blood flow and then you're
gonna start focusing more on increasing
the girth of the actual shaft so
you can actually quite easily tailor
your your joking exercises
depending upon your specific goals and
obviously they're like uh they're like
the best time of day to do this like
when you're in the shower when you're
done having sex you know when you're
masturbating yeah i wouldn't do it
free but don't do it before sex because
you'll sort of wear out your junk and
you'll wear
your you're sort of causing my remember
you're causing micro tears basically
in the the blood vessels and the cells
of the penile shaft
so it's just like you know if you're
going not that different not that
dissimilar to if you're
you know doing a bicep curl or if i'm
doing a tricep tricep extension in the
gym and then i go play basketball my
jump shot's going to be off right
so it's immediately afterwards you want
to give it some time to sort of
refresh and heal up got it
i like to do it first thing in the
morning get it out of the way then it's
that's sort of my morning route
part of my morning routine involves a
bunch of these exercises and things i
talk about in my book
so then bang it's done my shaft can rest
for the day
and then if i have a lady friend over
that night then i'm good to go so
my my appendage has the day to relax
okay so
tip number one learn what jelking is
there's there's
there's probably lots of stuff on the
internet that explains the movement
because it's not
it's not new it's not like sterling
invented this i mean you should be able
to find this stuff for free
i know that you've got all the details
in your course and in your book as well
and you know while we're talking about
it let me just drop it for you guys
there
second it's like i believe it came from
the middle east actually it's like a
really yeah it's a
releasing technique i mean it's nothing
more than a muscle like you know they
call it a boner but there's no bones in
there it's just it's just straight up
you know like
muscle tissue basically yeah
so this is all right so so we got joking
so what's next
first thing you could do the first thing
you do you could do a joking the second
free exercise i'm going to give you guys
right now
is actually manual stretching so
uh this is a technique that was there's
a there's a old
what are they called like a broadway
show but a stage show called
puppetry of the penis oh yeah and these
guys do all kind of funny like tricks
with their with their wang and they
make the wrist watch and they make the
make it look like an eiffel tower and
all kinds of funny stuff
they actually have weights that you can
hang off your
so those are those guys to do
to get it flexible enough for them to do
their show
you can do this without ways you can do
this just by
manually stretching it so basically
if you where's my hand so that's so
basically what you want to do let's
pretend this microphone is my
wang for a second if uh can you see me
yes excellent
if this is say the front part here say
like the glands
of your of your shaft you can grip
like this and then you can
start to pull you good so you're
gripping behind the base of the glass
you don't the
important thing is the glands is like a
really the most sensitive part of your
dick so you don't want to be like
doing any stretching you don't want to
be breaking anything you're saying don't
be doing anything
nasty there but behind it then you can
pull in various directions right and you
can pull and you can hold
at tension and what you're doing with
this is you're you're stretching the
ligaments
that attach your shaft to your pubic
bone and that
that causes it to hang basically further
away from your body
and increase your total erect length
can you talk about that penis extension
surgery that's been going around a lot
because i've seen you tweet about it how
it doesn't really do anything
no dude crap uh so i don't want guys
going out and paying ten thousand
dollars thinking that they're gonna
extend the size of their dick and
get it yes yeah i'm glad you asked it um
yeah so with with penis enlargement
surgery what they do
so you have your shaft and then there's
ligaments which attach it to the pubic
bone right
so in the enlargement surgery what they
do is they just sever
the ligaments that attach it to your
pubic bone instead of say instead of
like it hanging here it hangs
there but this doesn't actually change
the length
of the shot the penile shaft itself
so when it's flaccid it might it looks
like it's a bit longer
because the part that comes out of your
body is
already out of your body because they
cut the ligaments that attach it
but when you get a wreck it's still the
exact same size so guys are out there
paying 10
for enlargement surgery and all they're
getting is a better looking wang in the
locker room it's making no impact
on love life and they spent
10 grand it's like good lord what a
waste of money yeah if you want to
impress guys in the change room at the
gym
go get the surgery yeah basically uh
so it's it's utterly useless so with
this manual stretching though
you're elongating the attachment
and eventually you're along and you're
all along
the actin itself by applying this
pressure so you can
it's again it's kind of hard for me to
show this in real time
uh on richard's channel but think of it
like a clock
right you've got all these different
directions you can kind of
pull and this is also while i'm on the
topic this is also where you can sort of
correct
uh the curvature of your penis if you
say for example you pull to the left
which i used to i used to pull quite
significantly to the left now i'm
far more straight so like you can say
for example if i want to
a routine for for manual stretching
might be
i pull up i hold it up for two minutes i
hold it down for two minutes
i hold it to the right for two minutes i
hold to the left for two minutes right
it might be like a beginner's routine if
i'm if i
hang if i swing to the left then i might
pull it to the right for an extra minute
to start correcting
the uh the curvature of it so that's
just another thing you guys can focus on
and the same thing goes for up and down
if you if you naturally point up
you can make it like go a bit straighter
and that also just makes it look
longer in general because you've
corrected the curvature but
that's just more of an aesthetic thing
than an actual practical thing
completely free ways that you can go
about like extending the thing
okay
you